depuis lundi de salariés du site de
production sodexo à dreux ont entamé une
grève de la faim
la fermeture du site a été annoncée en
septembre pour des raisons
d'adaptabilité aux attentes du marché
les solutions proposées aux salariés
sont jugées indécentes par ces
manifestants un troisième les a rejoint
mardi en soutien
on en est venu à faire une grève de la
faim tout simplement parce qu'on
n'arrive pas à faire entendre la
direction de sodexo que le pse qui nous
ont qu'ils ont mis en place qui a été
signé et validé par les différents
syndicats est complètement en dehors des
attentes des salariés
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on se fait
licencier on compte trois francs six
sous on nous propose des reclassements à
plus de 100 kilomètres de chez nous pour
des salaires minimums et c'est
complètement intolérables
on se bat vous qu'aujourd'hui les
négociations soient réouvertes et que la
direction puisse recevoir les délégués
syndicaux pour qu'il est vraiment des
négociations sérieuses et descentes
le mois dernier une trentaine de
salariés protesté déjà devant le siège
social de l'entreprise à guyancourt
la direction se défend d'avoir négocié
dans les règles avec les partenaires
sociaux
au total le site de production de dreux
comptait 62 salariés dont six ont déjà
été ou sont en voie de reclassement ce
que devrait proposer dans le cadre de la
négociation entre les partenaires
sociaux a fait l'objet de quatre
réunions de négociation on a pu au
travers des échanges que l'on a fait
prendre en compte leurs attentes
adapter les dispositifs proposés et la
majorité de nos partenaires partenaires
sociaux ont signé cet accord
donc j'attends effectivement ce que
disent ces personnes qui dans la
situation ne touche que nous prenons en
compte qui nous préoccupe à l'heure
actuelle pour autant la signature de
l'ensemble de la majorité de nos
partenaires sociaux aujourd'hui prévost
et c'est bien les solutions pour chacun
des collaborateurs dans le cadre de cet
accord que l'on soit de pouvoir mettre
en oeuvre à présent l'entreprise de
restauration collective espère une
reprise du site et le maintien d'une
vingtaine de postes en fin de semaine
une commission de suivi aura lieu sur le
site de dreux avec les partenaires
sociaux